Um,
so what I want to do today is resist the
temptation to talk about anarchism the
entire time.
Um,
and I sent around the terms for today
of which I only forgot one or two. Uh,
so what I think I'll do at the beginning,
and I'm going to talk about, um, uh,
very quickly about socialism and the
difference between Revolutionary Socialism
and Reform Socialism,
add cynical ism to the mix.
And these are all terms
that I sent to you.
So I'm not going to write them on
the board because I need the board.
And then for most of the lecture,
I'm gonna talk about anarchism up because
anarchist didn't want to reform the
state.
They didn't want to seize control of
state either by revolution or by electoral
process.
They wanted to destroy the state.
And so I'm going to talk about
those guys, uh, for a while. And,
and most anarchists were not terrorists,
but at the end, I'm going to talk about,
uh, a guy that I followed her
on for four or five years, um,
who was a terrorist and arguably,
uh, as a book I just finished. Uh,
we can find the origins of
modern terrorism in this
guy who's called Amy on me.
And this will fit into Paris is obviously
sort of a sub theme in this course. Um,
and so as the state of the
capitalism and, and, uh,
this particular person and
me all, he set out to, uh,
uh,
to bomb and to kill and his
targets changed the name
of the game for terrorists.
And so that's obviously what I'm,
uh, uh, can't wait to talk about.
But first I'm going to just
review briefly for you.
It's getting brief or every second day.
Think about this. Uh, the socialist stuff,
which you can read about,
uh, and, uh, as, uh, the,
the rise with the rise of
mass politics in Europe, uh,
in the 1880s and 1890s, uh,
there was the rise of mass,
uh, socialist parties. Now
basically just to review,
uh,
there are two kinds of socialism.
There were the Revolutionary
Socialists, uh, who believed that,
uh, of which marks, this was an obvious
example. Uh, and his son in log,
Paul [inaudible] a name.
You don't have to retain a who brought
Marx's theory to France who believed
that, um, revolution would come when
the proletariat was class conscious.
Uh,
and uh,
after a bourgeois revolution of which he
basically thought 1848 had been a good
example following in 1789 and they're
proletariat would rise up and break their
chains and bring this brave new world.
Um, and so there were revolutionary
socialists, uh, in Italy,
in Spain and in France and
even a few in Germany. Um,
and then reform socialist said,
look,
states are becoming stronger
and stronger and can,
can break revolutions, uh, very easily.
Look what happened to the Paris commune
of 1871 went about 25,000 people are
massacred men,
women and children are gun down.
And that the way to bringing social
reform and abolishing the abuses of
capitalism is to reform.
And this is the reformist
tradition in Germany.
It's identified with somebody who in the
book, Barron's team, Edward Branch team,
and you can see this in the
growth of the SBA day, the,
the German Socialist
Party reformist party,
which was the largest party.
And there I stock, um,
in 1914 when war breaks out.
And so what you do is if you organize,
you can pat get get legislatures.
If you, if you have enough, uh,
socialists and enough, a well meaning
other people in, uh, in, uh, the,
uh, legislatures. And then
when I stock or in the show,
I'm the deputy or the other parliaments
and places that had parliaments,
then you can vote in law.
You can vote in a mine safety regulations
because mine's killed so many people.
Mining accidents killed so many people.
There's one of the [inaudible] were
hundreds and hundreds of people as a
thousand people get killed in one
accident. And about 1910 or 1911, uh,
you, uh, you can pass a, an
eight hour day or a 10 hour day.
You can pass laws making it a harder
and harder to employ children,
particularly in dangerous
tasks. Uh, you can, uh,
you can do things for women. You
could do things for families. Uh,
if you elect the right kind of people,
um,
you can have a revolution through reform,
through the ballot and the great
socialist leaders such as Berenstein,
whom I just mentioned, or the
Great John Shaw has, whose death,
whose death on the 31st of July.
Uh,
1914 was really the end of an era
and the beginning of another era,
uh, scary year of the war. And then
people had that sense, uh, you know,
he was the one who in France unified the
socialists and, and, and the revolution,
the reform socialists and
revolutionary socialists. Uh,
though there are still a fishers in
their, in their approaches. And of course,
the old revolutionary socialists would
become the communists after 1920 when the
social economy, the French
Communist Party is, uh,
is begun in the wake of the Russian
revolution, which seemed to be a Rev. Uh,
even though it was one
revolution, uh, in a,
in a very complex situation that seemed
to say that you can't have a revolution.
Uh, but anyway, uh, so reform,
socialists dominate in Germany, uh,
they dominate in France.
They dominated in Belgium,
the Socialist Party is
terribly important, uh, in,
in Italy they become more
important and in Spain as well.
And so those are the two big,
uh, big, uh, uh, traditions. Um,
now some of the tensions
between Revolutionary
Socialists and reform socialists
can be seen in the fact that
Revolutionary Socialists said, look,
if you are working in that you're in the
right stock and you're trying to get a
better insurance plans. Ironically, it
was Bismarck who Bismarck's Germany.
That gives really the first substantial
insurance program for, for workers.
Um, what's you're doing is you're
propping up the bourgeois state,
you're buying into it,
you're, you're, uh, uh,
you're supporting indirectly their armies,
uh, that crush workers and strikes.
And they did. And the heroic
age of symbolism were more
about that in a minute.
1895 to about 1907 in France.
But in other countries it's about the
same thing. Um, so you're propping up the,
uh, the bourgeois state by
participating in electoral politics. So,
but lots of revolutionary socialists.
And this is Alma Book. Uh,
so don't worry about this, but a lot
of them sort of say, well, look, we've,
if we don't run candidates and elections,
how are they going to know about us?
So they, they too would run
candidates in elections.
So there put it really kind of class,
same.
They're really sort of stuck between a
rock and a hard place because they're
running candidates in elections
in which they do not believe. Um,
so,
uh,
I'm not here talking about Russia
because that is more complicated with the
Bolsheviks and the Mensheviks and
the socialist revolutionaries.
And we will come back to them. I'm
talking basically about, uh, uh,
about western Europe and you have to
imagine that lending and the other,
the other Russian socialist is, or
our serve walking around, uh, uh,
the lakes of Geneva and in Missouri can
in exile and trying to imagine this, uh,
this future. But that's the big difference
between a, a socialist reform and, uh,
uh, in Revolutionary Socialists. Now
to make things even more complicated,
you have a group called syndicate lists
and the word Cindy, a cynical list.
It's an English word syndicate list,
which I sent along on your,
I know a friendly email from
yours. Truly, I'm a cynic.
Lists of word comes from
the French word for unions,
which is a San Diego [inaudible].
And what they said it, hang on,
they kind of lead with the revolutionary
socialist at saying if you get involved
in electoral process, you are propping up
this crop borzois state. You are a con,
you're propping up this dynamic
duo of the state and capitalism.
And they say cynically say,
look,
we will organize from the ground up
beginning in the shop, the shop floor,
the factory and that that will be not
only a means to obtain a revolution,
it will be a means.
It's a way of,
of seeing what the future world will
life will be like when everybody to twice
everybody or dues everybody. Uh,
and, and the kind of relations,
the friendly equal relations
of the shop floor, uh, uh,
become after the revolution become
the way the world will be organized.
And in the south of Europe and Italy
and in Spain, these folks are called,
and I sent this around too,
and our co cynical lists,
you'll see a transition here and
our coasts into dickless, uh,
and because they're rejecting the state
and they're looking in the future.
And the decentralized
organization, uh, is part of it.
And anarcho lists, uh, have
considerable influence in, in, uh,
in Spain and Italy.
Uh,
they believe in direct action
and sabotage and strikes,
but in union organization, uh,
and one of the most interesting,
I mentioned him in the book, but, uh,
for now I'm Poo ta who was sort of
theorist a, p, e, l, l, O, u, t, I,
e r pollute Aa a who wrote a
book called the dying society,
was one of the theoreticians of Anarcho
Syndicate, colorism of syndicate wisdom.
And he himself was dying. He was dying
of TB, though he was not a worker,
tuberculosis. What's working
class disease? Go to Pennsylvania,
go to West Virginia, you know,
tuberculosis, the ravages of the minds.
And the United States were just
incredible. And in, you know,
porcelain factories and all sorts
of places, uh, glass factories,
uh,
all over the place.
And Pilou ta a crate sees thing is
called Labor or he's one of the,
the people who come to these things called
Labor exchanges and wants to provide,
you call them in French,
but labor exchanges,
which were towns where you had municipal
socialists in power at the municipality
level, the municipal level and
you did in some cities, uh, are,
are giving municipal funds to
start these labor exchanges,
which are buildings you can still see
them. Uh, when I was invited to, you know,
limos to give a big talk about
the book by the Confederation,
which I don't know how to do,
to go via,
I mean the first we started
the APP at a whole, you know,
the first round of drinks about noon
in the labor exchange and amaze on,
do put up the host of the people.
And they were places where workers coming
from other places could come and get a
meal, get some money and above
all find out about jobs. So,
so for says Sin Nicholas,
the way of imagining the future and
preparing for this brave new world of post
revolutionary, uh, relationships, uh,
that has an important privileged
place in the way they view the world.
And there was an engineer
called the Joshes.
So Hella whose name I should've sent
you around, sor, e, l, a, s, O, r, e,
l. And he comes to the notion of the
general strike that one day, all workers.
So simply simply put down their tools
and say, hell with you, capitalism.
Hell we you the state, uh, and they
will bring in capitalism to its knees.
It doesn't really ever work out
that way, does it, you know,
the capitalists and
the state when the day.
So having rushed through all of that,
let me talk about what I want to talk
about and that is anarchism of which
there's only a couple,
uh,
short and I hope sprightly
paragraphs in which you're reading.
And I am not an anarchist.
I was unsorted sometimes
when I give talks, you know,
various places of Saint Louis recently
and other places, people at the end,
we'll think,
hopefully they'll never think I'm a
terrorist because I'm certainly not. Uh,
and when I talk about this guy, I do not,
so with affection or admiration, but I,
I know him because I followed him
around. I followed him around. Um,
uh, but I want to have taco and
most anarchists. We're not, uh,
we're not terrorists.
And when one wants to make that clear,
it's not surprising that,
that the,
the great strengths of anarchism are in
Spain and Catalonia and an under Lucilia
in the south of Spain
and in southern Italy.
Why?
Because that's where the Italian and
the Spanish states have very limited
success in convincing people
that they're Spanish or Italian.
And why should they believe
they're Spanish or Italian?
With his southern Italians thought that,
that the republic was a, or the monarchy,
but the progressive
monetary so called was, uh,
was a plot launched by tax collectors
and industrial capitalist in the north of
Italy and in under Lucilia, uh,
and, and in, in Catalonia where,
or the garden Savella who were attended
to me from Galicia of conservative part
of Spain.
Where were the odious Franco was from a,
or from a custody, uh, you know, the
area around Madrid, huge area run Madrid.
Uh,
it was easy to see how they associated
the state was something that they didn't
want. But in, in writing about anarchism,
I tried to put myself in to try to
think of how anarchist viewed the world.
And I'm going to tell you a
story that's a true story,
but if you're trying to
imagine how anarchist, uh,
viewed the world of this story
is not a bad one. It's about,
um,
a core coworker,
cork worker making corks for bottles
of Sherry in the south of Spain.
And he's dying.
And He'd been an anarchist his entire
life and he hated the state and he hated
capitalism and he hated
the church and he's dying.
He's not as death bit.
And he had married a woman from a
religiously practicing Catholic family.
And so in the scene in this room in which
he's dying in one part of the room is
his,
his family who hated organized religion,
who view it as a prop for
capitalism and the state.
And then the other side of the room where
people who are not so sure they went
to church sometime who knew the priest
and when he's lying there,
the end is near.
His wife's family says,
Pedro,
don't you want me to bring a lawyer
in a lawyer who will take your will,
your last will?
And our kids don't have wills and
they don't have very much property.
This is the other side of the
room's just utter terror, horror.
How can they suggest such a thing
that Pedro's going to make a will?
That's a bourgeois thing
to do to make a will.
And then somebody else from his wife's
family says, Pedro, the end is near.
Don't you want us to get a
priest for the last rites?
He never set foot in a church and proudly
so consternation on the other side of
the room.
How will it all end?
How will Pedro ended his life
with a lawyer and a priest.
And so Pedro looks up and he says, go
and get me a lawyer, bring me a lawyer.
And then he says,
go and tell father the Qa,
the priest to come to see me.
Joy,
utter consternation.
Pedro's lying in a bed in the middle.
So pretty soon the lawyer comes
dress dressing his little suit.
He doesn't yet have a calculator to tote
up the bill, but he's got his legal pad.
He's never been in that house before.
And he comes down,
he by the bed and he says,
Pedro,
you have a few possessions of fork,
a knife,
a couple of plates.
Don't you want to give me your will now?
And Pedro says, wait a
minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute. And then the priest
comes and he's has his red is,
it's a purple, because I remember
this from Jesuit high school days.
He has his purple,
uh,
thing that they were on Easter
and he has his little case also,
which he has the holy oil to bless
Pedro and give him the last rites.
And he comes close and he
says, Pedro, the end is near.
You've led a good life,
but I haven't seen you in church
very much or ever for that matter.
And your children are not baptized.
Don't you want to make a confession?
You're going to make,
meet your maker soon.
Don't you want to make a confession to me
right now? Nobody, they can't hear you.
Don't you have something you
want me to tell you that you did?
You want to tell me in? There's
something I can tell you. I mean,
you can tell me and I
will tell you whatever.
And so consternation in one side,
silent joy and the other.
And so Pedro says to the lawyer,
he says, come here Senor. He says,
I want you to stand on
the left side of my bed.
And he says to the priest,
father, father, come here please.
I want you to sit or stand
on the right side of my bed.
And then he smiles,
a smile of utter contentment.
And he says,
now you can all see to both sides
of the family that like Christ,
I am dying between two
thieves and he died.
And to imagine the kind of hate that
anarchist had of soldiers and priests and
of officials and if could
Stiliyan Garda Savita,
that was how anarchism was born.
Now when was anarchism born?
There's a couple of antecedents
in the 18th century,
but they're terribly relevant
people that hardly anyone read,
including a British one.
It really starts with poodle.
A name I sent around pl has
was f, a poodle, p, r, O, u,
d. H. O. N. And he was
from the east of France,
from around Bezel,
from Desmond's hall in the East.
And the mountain is function conte.
And he believed that if you didn't have
the state than people could live pretty
much as with a little bit of prosperity,
that they had a few chickens,
a little piece of land. Uh, people
tended to live like that. There.
It was a place where nobody had very much,
but everybody had enough
to get along and he writes,
the following is my lecture notes
to be governed is to be watched,
inspected,
spied upon directed, law-driven,
numbered, regulated, enrolled,
indoctrinated, preached at controlled,
checked, estimated, valued, censored,
commanded by creatures who have neither
the right nor the wisdom northern virtue
to do so to be governed at every
operation that every transaction noted.
Registered, counted, tax stamped,
measured number to assess, licensed,
authorized admonish, prevented,
forbidden, reformed, corrected,
punished under the pretext of the use
of public utility and the name of the
general interest and it's been placed
under taxes, drilled, fleeced, exploited,
monopolized, extorted from
squeezed, hoped and robbed.
And that decided this resistance that
the first word of complaint to be
repressed, fired, vilified, harassed,
hunted down, abused, clubbed,
disarmed, bound, choked, imprisoned,
judged, condemn, shot, deported,
sacrificed, sold, betrayed and
to crown. All mocked, ridiculed,
derided, outraged, dishonored that
has government that it's as justice,
that it's morality.
He wrote a book,
a pamphlet in 1841 called what
is property? Question Mark.
And his answers property is theft.
Now,
he didn't mean it all property was theft.
What he meant was too much property was
theft or unearned property was theft.
And Perdomo had lots of
influence among some hesitance,
but mostly artisans in the
world by the way, that that, uh,
the great painter Gustava Akuna Bay,
uh,
painted a lot in the area around Besan
zone or no burial of or known lots of
really marvelous, uh, uh, paintings
of people at work, the stone breakers,
people just working their guts out
for very little and Perdomo. Uh,
in 1848, it said, he went
down in Paris and put, put a,
a brick on a barricade and threw up
nauseated by the thought of violence of
revolution and his successors.
So the leaders of the anarchist
movements were Michael Bakunin,
whose name is in there,
be a kit, k, u, N, I,
N and enormously tall bearded,
heavy drinking, heavy eating,
heavy sweating, Russian noble,
a prince who was an anarchist who
said the revolution will come.
It will come with a single spark and all
the hundreds of millions of toilers to
surf will rise up and they will slay
their social betters and create this new
brave world based upon their
village harmonies. And he said,
destruction is a creative passion,
quote unquote honored gimme
destruction is a creative passion.
And in 1848,
he led police on a merry chase.
He spent a time in the Russian slam air.
He escapes through Japan,
goes through the United States, ends
up back in London, terrified people,
his image,
I mean,
this is before photographs
are just photographs are
just starting out and there
are photographs of him.
And he met marks who he
hated and Mark's hated him.
He thought that Marx was ruining class.
Struggle was ruining
revolution by preaching over
and over again about waiting
for revolution class conscious workers.
What you need is peasants to
rise up as they had in Pooka,
Jeff's rebellion and all the other
rebellions in the early to 17th and 18th
century. He dies in the
early 1870s, you know,
a phenomenal, uh, a character
and the other Russian,
a gentle man, a geographer,
Peter Kropotkin,
k Oop, Ots, k, I, n.
K. R. O. P. Kropotkin. Yeah.
Kropotkin is in the book. And he
wrote a pamphlet that, that, uh,
called the anarchist morality.
When you get rid of the state,
people are basically good anarchist.
Believe that people are good.
If there's a tradition from loose
sold by the way there to who,
so who lived in east of France or what
would become France around Shambhavi who
believed in the primitive and our kiss
believed that primitive social relations
and even primitive ways of producing
things. Uh, uh, Oregon, you know,
just associations. You enter in
because you want to, uh, we're the,
we're the future.
And Kropotkin who at the end of his life
was once toasted by the King of England
and who had turned against
the Russian revolution.
He dies and I think 1921 or 22,
he was terrified by it,
just as disgusted by
the Russian revolution,
which was already creating a
centralized state. That's what he hated.
He hated states, you must destroy
the state. But he was a gentle man,
yet he and a guy called Paul Boosie,
you don't have to remember who became
a socialist leader and then went nuts
later. Uh, uh, he was just
in a very clinical term, but
he had big problems. Uh, uh,
later,
uh,
they create the term
propaganda by the deed.
What is a deed?
A deed is a bomb or Adidas,
an attack. It's the murder of
an official. Now, they weren't,
the anarchist weren't the
only one doing this stuff.
And there was a Russian group briefly
mentioned called neurod Novela Vola who
believed in kind of a hierarchical system,
post revolutionary system.
And what they want to do is
set out and kill officials,
but soda of anarchist terrorists
and they killed officials.
One of which you've heard of already.
You probably heard some of the others.
President Mckinley 1901 buffalo,
New York is killed by somebody
who's got received funds from a, uh,
an anarchist organization in New
Jersey, I think in Paterson, New Jersey.
Where is that brushy at
anyway? Brushy kills, um, cane.
When beer till the second of Italy,
another anarchist assassination,
they kill five or six, uh,
uh, leaders. Uh, during this
period of anarchist heyday,
really the late 19th century,
uh, king owned be octo.
The second of Italy said that he
considered a assassination or professional
risk.
There were two attempts on his life and
the third one nails him and Alexander
the second who liberated
the serfs. He is killed. Uh,
when he gets out of a sled to look at a
bomb that doesn't work. And Elizabeth,
the emperor of Austria,
Hungary who couldn't stand fronds
Yosef and lived apart from him,
she is assassinated as well.
But most anarchist,
we're not. Uh, we're not killers.
Now, if you think of American history,
those of you who've had Glenda's course
or David Blights, other people here,
you might know about Haymarket,
the Haymarket affair and the 1880s and
there they hang for anarchists who are
called late Poland do in France. He had
enormous influence. The pointed with,
ah Ha, the ha the hang is
there swinging in the breeze.
And the Chicago prison yard.
Uh,
they were anarchists and they inspire
someone like Emma Goldman who was a
Russian Jewish immigrant,
an immigrant to the United States.
It becomes an important
American anarchist,
but anarchist set off to
kill a policeman or to kill,
to kill heads of state
or to kill generals,
propaganda by the deed, the spark
that will ignite this revolution.
But the man you see before you,
and I've become today a very modern man.
I want to tell you,
cause this is my first try at PowerPoint.
The person I see you that you see before
is the guy who been following around.
And I got interested
in him for two reasons.
One is that he is the first
really along with a bombing at,
at an opera in Barcelona at the list
you'll in Barcelona to target ordinary
people.
And to say that people have a social
class were guilty because they were who
they were. And that the spark does not
necessarily have to be lit by killing,
killing a ahead of a state as
study carnow who would get his,
uh, in 1894 on the route of
the road public in, in Lille,
president of France.
He takes the decision to kill ordinary
people and lots of terrorists since then
have taken that decision, that
kind of a classic example, uh,
insurgents in, in, in, in, you
know, in Puente job and in, in,
in India and in the 1920s, you
know, bombing officers' clubs.
There's terrifying scene in that.
Fantastic but very difficult movie
because of the torture scene.
I can't even use it in the French history
course, the battle of Algiers. Uh,
where you,
that you are with this woman
who's planting a bomb and
a cafe and she sees the
people who are going to die.
She sees babies with their mother or
she sees people having a drink, uh,
in the French community there and she
takes the decision to place the bomb.
I believe that it kind of started
with this guy, and this is, again,
not somebody I admire. I know him. I
followed him everywhere. He has lived.
I haven't been.
Um,
and I guess if you're going to write
a book about somebody as a prism on
something, whether it's good to pick
somebody who only lived to be 21,
because the shorter book
he was guillotined in May,
1894, uh, and again, I do not admire him,
but I'm going to tell you about them
anyway with the help of PowerPoint.
And so how the hell do I do this? I got
to remember how to do this. All right,
that's a meat on me.
His father was a commune out who
is commit condemned to death.
Somebody who'd fought in the commune.
And so this guy is born in Spain and his
father contracted and mercury poisoning
in Spain and comes back to France
after the amnesty and dies.
And he has an older brother
and a younger brother.
And what he does is a,
an a day in 1894,
he sets out with a bomb
and he goes down to,
uh, he walks in the fancy
boulevards that for him, uh,
uh,
re represent all of the class differences
between wealthy and poor people,
center versus periphery and all of that.
He goes down to the cafe Termi News,
which is on your right.
It's those awnings there near the Garth's.
Now those are the cafe terminus. I've had
the rather odd experience of twice, uh,
once with friends and once with my son
having eaten in the restaurant that my
book's subject blew up because it's still
there and sitting at the same table.
He goes to four or five cafes, but they're
not enough innocent people in them.
So it goes to the terminus where
there was a gypsy orchestra playing,
pays for two beers.
That seems a little odd anarchist paying
for beer because the right to theft was
something that they still believed
in. Many of them, not all,
and most were not terrorists.
Remember that? Uh,
he goes in to the cafe to
look something like that.
I though what's happening here,
mass,
you know, uh, so am I'm supposed
to say things like that. Anyway,
he goes in to the cafe term, he knows,
and then he a cigar. He lights the fuse,
he throws it up toward a chandelier and
it blows up killing one and wounding
about 18 people. That's not him. And
this anarchist that's called Mala Testa,
who doesn't look particularly scary there,
but Amit,
all he had gone back to Paris or to
the Paris region is his mother had a,
um, had a, a very pitiful, oh bears.
This is the era of bomb attacks in the
early 1890s. That's a Ma, Amit, that's a,
as bombs are sometimes
called. Um, and he, uh,
he became an anarchist.
His brother had already
become an anarchist and to
put yourself into the early
1890s in Paris,
ordinary people,
but not so much as the
elites were terrified of.
And our cusp bombers Raba Shola a
name I sent around who was a poor,
pathetic in many ways, but extremely poor
guy who'd been sent out to beg by his,
by his mother.
Uh,
they had almost no money there from
place called Sasha Mall near Santa Tn.
Ahava shoal, uh, um,
was a counterfeiter and finally a
murderer. He suffocated to death.
A hermit who had had a mini
fortune hidden in his bizarre,
a cottage,
a near Santa Tn.
He escapes from the police
and he goes to Paris in 1891.
Police beat the hell out of
three anarchists in a march.
I'd rather one sided, uh,
a brawl. Uh, and two of them are
condemned to big time sentences.
A robble shoal decides to go and to kill
the prosecuting attorney and he places
a bomb not knowing where the apartment
was and the bomb blows up. Uh,
and um, then he, uh, he
had said other bombs to,
and then after having done this,
he goes to a restaurant and he,
and he eats rather well, and he engages
a waiter in conversation and he cries.
He convinced the waiter to be an anarchist
and the waiter cc has a scar on his
left hand.
Robert Shoulder did.
And then he stupidly goes back later
and eats in the same restaurant.
And the set of bringing the second course.
The waiter brings the police
and after a tremendous struggle,
Hava shoal is captured,
put on trial for his life
and he memorably holds up.
God Damn it.
How do you work this thing?
I'm supposed to talk like that.
Anyway, he is load. All right. He is.
He is Ghia teen and he's really kind of
a bastard. I mean not more than that.
He turned and he had killed
other people too probably,
but he finally has guillotine.
But what happens is the two things happen,
and not only in Paris but in other places,
is that over that the people of means
living in the fancy quarters are extremely
frightened and they're all sorts of
death threats that get sent around,
but we'll have a shool to those anarchists
terrorists. He becomes a martyr. Look,
I'm here as the head is in the, in the, in
the, in the is framed by the guillotine.
Rava shoal who'd been betrayed by a,
an anarchist friend,
dies at age 33.
Christ died at age 33,
betrayed by a friend.
And so he becomes the serve,
not for radical anarchist.
He becomes a vision of how life should
be and their songs called La have ashore
or, and there's another one called
the dynamite polka being son,
because dynamite from the point of view
of anarchists leveled the playing field.
And they viewed dynamite rather as the
way in which muskets helped in the domain
of feudalism.
Uh,
it levels the playing field and
dynamite after all was invented by who?
By no bell,
as in the Nobel prize.
And so the people who support diamond
dynamite in French or called the Dean Dean
and me tie the dynamite and the
dynamite polka in [inaudible].
And where you have a lot of
anarchist writers and artists, um,
Pizarro is an anarchist,
uh, and the literary, uh,
the art critic and literary and
art critic above all art, uh,
Felix defend y'all who was a friend of
a meat only as an Arnica anarchist, uh,
as well. So it's end of this world
that, uh, the young Amy agree,
here you go. Here's this one
of, I read hundreds of these
things. Uh, this, it said,
you, you, you've always been a
hard with your domestics. Uh,
you're going to be blown
up a desk to the richest.
There are hundreds of these things.
They're all sent all over Paris,
not just the fancy neighborhoods. And
there are many times, not many times,
but I didn't, I had been in
hundreds and hundreds of times,
but at the airport you hear
these explosions sometimes
as they blow up suitcases
that haven't been claimed.
That's the first known, you know,
machine that blows up a suspect items
including lots of bad jokes and when
sardine cans with a little bit of a powder
left in them and that kind of thing.
Um,
so it's in this world that [inaudible]
learns to hate and that he certainly,
uh, he certainly does. That's
where his mom had her obash. Uh,
ironically it's near
Youhow Disney, uh, now,
but then it was a village that's not the
one that was up the street a little bit.
So I did follow them around.
You can see,
and there's his mother there and up on
the right is the place he lived in. Um,
one of the places he lived always around
except for one occasion around we'll
mask. And that's his, his
girlfriend. He had unrequited love.
She had the disadvantage of being married
to another anarchist and he writes her
clumsy poems. He falls in love with her.
She blows him off. Uh, but in the end,
she wanted to take full credit before
the press for having been the lover of
Immuno knee after his deeds,
his bombs. But he wasn't a,
and that's one of the places he worked
at Paris. I love that because see,
you hear that,
that's a beautiful sign.
And that company hasn't
existed since World War One,
but you can follow him around.
And then in 1892 and meet
on Henri two years earlier,
he had killed before there was a strike
in the south and France and Camo glass
workers in Camo.
And so the third block on
the left is number 11, and
that's where the company is.
And, uh, they found a bomb. They're
placed about 11 in the morning, uh,
right there. That's not the way it
looked. Then I've gotten in there,
I've gotten in there twice a to
see where he placed the bomb.
My son gets a little tired dad, we have
to look at another one of these places.
Uh, they find the bomb and they carry
it down to uh, uh, the police station,
which is still there and
it was a reversible bomb,
which means I'm in the chemicals
running together. Boom. And it blew.
It kills five people,
terribly. Five policemen in a
secretary among them, you know,
body parts just all over
the place and meet Henri is,
that's one of the places he lived.
He is eliminated from the list of suspects
because they said he could not have
gone on the two errands is his boss sent
that day from near the station of the
north down toward the center of Paris,
then up toward the Arc de Triomphe gone
back to [inaudible] and gotten the bomb,
placed the bomb and got back in two
hours and 15 minutes when he went to his
trial for his life. When he went on trial
for his life in 1894, uh, detective said,
yeah, he could have done that
in two hours and 15 minutes.
So being a bit of an impure
assist, I did it. Uh,
and I replaced Treadway and Omani
booths with a bus and with a metro.
I never take cabs, but I took a
instead of a carriage, of course not,
didn't take that I took a cab and I
subtracted 11 minutes when my cab couldn't
turn left on the Avenue
Lopez. Um, and, um, he did it.
There's no question about it.
In fact,
when they did the
reconstitution of this building,
he knew every single part
of this building. He did it.
There's no question about it. Um, and why
did he hate so well, part of it, again,
that this is the theme
we've talked about before,
was the social geography of Paris.
Everywhere he lived with one exception
that you just saw was in people's Paris
and all of the facades are still there.
Um,
that's where he lived on the roof
of that home. It doesn't name,
that's where he lived in the very top
floor. That's where the poor lived.
He gets the bomb there in 1892 and they
hated sock recur for reasons you already
know because it was a symbol of penance
for the Franco Prussian war and pennants
for the commune.
And his father was,
was one of the people condemned to death
who have lucky enough to get out and
not be executed. And there isn't a Zoloft,
no novel that's very underappreciated,
called Paris published in 1898.
It's about a priest who to take an
rem song is losing his religion.
Uh, and his brother is an
anarchist Guillaume and he
has fantasies about blowing
this place up. I think
it's ugly as hell, but,
and I once went with my wife to,
uh,
see where they cast the huge bell that
would drive people nuts and still does
called the Stavo. Yeah. But that
bill wasn't there. But as a symbol,
you can't walk around with masks
and not see it from various places.
And so he becomes a terrorist because
the people that he sees around him are
very rapport. And he convinces himself,
even though he's an intellectual,
he's a bourgeois. He could've
gotten into the coal, uh,
po putting technique, which
is a super, uh, groans a cold.
It's a big engineering school. He's a
great student. He's an intellectual.
And that's the other thing
besides picking innocent people,
quote unquote innocent people. All people
are innocent. But you know what I mean?
Uh, he, the other thing is about, he
is not a sad sack or dangerous one.
Like Ravi Shoal.
He is not a guy called [inaudible] who
places a little teeny tack bomb and
frozen the Chamber of Deputies,
uh,
to call attention to the plight
of the poor and his guillotine.
The first person in the 19th century
Ghia teen who did not kill somebody.
And so this guy goes out to kill.
There's a scene in an old Balzac
novel called um, um, oh, all of us up.
Balzac novels by definition
are old obviously, but,
but called the old [inaudible] hill in
which [inaudible] who sort of this down
and out noble who,
who wants to make the bid time big time
in Paris by sleeping with all the right
people. Uh, after go, he'll dies. Um,
he's up in the northeast quadrant of
Paris at parallel [inaudible] cemetery and
he waves his arms down his hand
down toward the fancy quarters down,
ironically near where the cafe terminus
would be the fancy quarters even before
their boulevards. And he
says the equivalent and
it's war between you and me.
Now baby, it's not, it's a rough
translation, but that's what he said.
Immune Henri walking around on the
hills and seeing people walk down to be
domestics because they
couldn't afford the,
to take the Tom way or the Omni boost
or draw a horse drawn carriages.
He waves his hand and says, it's
war between you and me, baby.
And I will ignite the spark
that kills you MFS right away.
And that's what he does.
And when he walked out of his apartment,
he looked down and you what?
Happily,
he didn't have to see the
tour Montparnasse which
hadn't been built after huge
payoffs in the early
1970s. This disgusting. Uh,
but what he could see his he symbols of
capitalism, the state and the church.
What did he see? He saw the top Eiffel
Tower, which was five years old,
a symbol of the Republican and the
bourgeois revolution as he saw it.
He sees the Ponti on where they buried
all these Napoleonic Marshall's who'd
basically got a lot of people killed
if they didn't get themselves killed.
And he sees North Dakota Dom and he says,
it's war between you and me. And this is
the facade. I mean, I love this stuff.
The inside building where he loved
his, where he lived isn't, uh,
isn't there anymore. And now it's kind
of an area that's a little bit sketchy.
There's a lot of drug dealing.
When I got myself into there,
I had to kind of didn't want to
look like a plain clothes policemen.
Do I rate risk looking like a
plainclothes policemen? No. Did I did,
I didn't want to look like a
tourist, you know, sort of slumming.
I don't look like that much either.
And when I went by these guys who were
sort of hanging out there, I said,
said Lou, they got, or something
like that, or hi guys, what's up? Uh,
and I got myself in there to
see where he wants had lived.
But the point of that is
that you can see what he saw.
And that gate is exactly the same is that
day when he walked out to kill for the
second time and his bomb that he
threw into the terminal newest.
Now this is back in 1894.
This is where we started.
It hit a chandelier and exploded.
And he said,
he said at his trial
that he threw it too low.
You should have thrown into higher.
It would have killed more people.
Only one died. He'd already killed five
before. Um, and then people are terrified.
They run all over the place. Uh,
it was speculated that it was,
his was sort of an indirect suicide
because his unrequited love this,
this lady you live and the Boulevard
Voltaire, uh, whose name was Elise, um,
at least, uh, really, uh, and, but no,
because he tries to escape in order
to kill again and they chase them.
They catch them. A Barbara helps catch
'em. Uh, a controller on the, on the, uh,
tramway hits him with the control
mechanism that punches tickets. Just like,
you know,
in the old days on those things,
not that I ever was in a
horse drawn carriage. Um,
and they get them and they take him.
Um,
he's arrested for murder and
we all agree, uh, and uh,
is put on trial.
That's where he's writing his mother.
We know a lot about him because, uh, cause
they kept all these, these documents.
So this is just, it was so fun doing this.
I love stuff like that, you know, and,
and his mother was devastated as you can.
Well,
imagine she could not believe that her
a meal immediate could've done this.
He was her pride and joy after
the death of the, uh, uh,
of the father and he's put in the sea.
Those of you have been to Paris will
recognize this as the concierge of me. Uh,
this is where Louis the 16th
don't tone hopes. Pierre,
a Marie Antoinette and other
is a weighted. They put
their head in between the,
you know,
the little window as they used to say
that petite [inaudible] to be gay teen.
It's also got one of the three amongst
magnificent gothic halls anywhere, uh,
in France.
And his guards took notes every single
day about what he said in the anarchist
songs. He, he, cause they want to be,
they want to prove that he had that
somebody else was involved in this.
And there probably was somebody else in
the 1892 attack who helped him close the
bomb. Um, so, uh, I mean long,
he goes on trial in,
in April of 1894 and he,
um,
he has, it makes the famous dex
declaration in which he says,
you have hung us in Chicago Haymarket.
You have guaranteed us that slowly
strangling us in Barcelona. Uh,
when Franco was croaking in 1975 a,
they were guaranteeing an anarchist,
even at that time,
1975 in Barcelona,
you've shot us in Germany. Uh, you have,
I don't know how they killed him in Italy,
but you have killed us in Italy.
And he says, um, you, uh, you,
the bourgeois, uh, who were in this cafe,
you're not innocent this because of you.
The petty bourgeois you support,
they grow the big ones on
every possible occasion. Uh,
you forget about us when you, uh,
when your factory owners throw us out,
when we can no longer work any longer,
uh,
or women workers happy not to have had
to prostitute themselves in order to pay
their rent and their husbands rent
by the, uh, by the end of the month.
But would you can ever do is destroy
anarchism is roots are too deep.
And he on the 22nd of May,
1894,
so I said about writing a book by
somebody doesn't live very long. Uh,
he is executed at rural cat in Paris,
which was by intent the place
where the state, uh, uh,
met it out justice right in the
heart of working class Paris.
That was not an idol selection of a
space. And we have his notes, you know,
up to the,
up to the very end of his life.
This guy de Blair is the executioner.
Uh,
Mr Piney and Mr Depakene,
uh, uh, this is, uh,
the execution or a meeting out in quotes,
justice.
The last public execution
by the way in France would,
does that mean I said this already
was in 1934 through 36 at side.
The last execution was in 1974 and I'm
constantly asked by people all sorts of
political opinions in France where
we're, uh, executions public, uh, uh,
capital punishment is reputed by most
everybody. How that we still have it here.
This is not a political,
a political diatribes.
So I won't say anything about
that anyway, but deep, deep there,
his son was the last public execution
or did the last public execution back
when, uh, there he is.
There's somebody else being putting
their head through the little window.
That's what I mean by that. Uh, and
uh, at all, no, we got to go back.
Okay. And that's is the equivalent
of his mugshot. Uh, uh, so,
uh,
he was wrong about the d the about
anarchism the roots of anarchism being too
deep. What clearly happens is
that, uh, there is a trial, uh,
the next, uh, uh,
during that same summer where they put
a lot of intellectuals on trial who did
nothing you can say,
except to say that there were anarchists
or criticized the state and what my
book is really a book also
about state terrorism.
It's about the over exaggerated
that overreaction of states would,
our state is a good example of that.
And, and the tendency to try to, to, uh,
denigrate anyone who doesn't agree
with us as being terrorists, uh,
whether they were or they're not,
and the intellectuals,
the jury sees through it in 1894, and,
and only a couple of thieves are, are,
are condemned and them, uh,
and then not to death. Um,
anarchism you know, there's the anarchist
in 1968 in Paris. They're anarchist.
There's a band of anarchist in about
19 nine, 1910, 1911 that hold up, uh,
uh, stores with most modern tools,
shotguns and things like that.
But the anarchist attacks were over.
There was no question about that.
That doesn't make any meal on re less
interesting as an intellectual at the
cross class kind of, and you see this
and in Middle Eastern terrorism too. Uh,
but my book is also about state
terrorism. What stops anarchism, uh, uh,
in, in well start stops
anarchist attacks in, uh,
in Spain is the fact that the public
becomes aware that the police were
hideously torturing people who did not
agree with the politics of the state.
They were torturing them. Um, you'll see
where this one could go in a political,
uh, uh, uh, diatribe, which this isn't a,
in Italy, when the state overreacts, uh,
anarchist, uh, attacks, uh, virtually end.
Now anarchism does not end in Spain.
It does not.
And also for reasons that are perfectly
clear already in Buenos Aires.
And there's still huge anarchist community
of exiles from these western European
countries from all over the place.
Uh, living in London. Ironically,
in one of the more she,
she have played parts of London,
which was then very poor
on Charlotte Street,
where you can't afford to have
a pint of beer anymore. Uh, and,
and that's where they lived.
But so he was wrong about that.
The roots of anarchism, uh, were too
great. But the connection, you know,
that I would make obviously, and this,
and especially since it's being filmed,
was not the place to do it. But when
states, including our own overreact, uh,
what they attend to do is to,
uh,
and lash out in ways and
in prison unjustly and in,
and torture and don't give legal
rights. What they do is tend to, uh, uh,
increase, uh, the number of those
people, uh, who, uh, despise us.
Uh, and if you look back,
and again, the communist,
not in a bad way of thinking about this,
somebody figured out that of all the
victims of anarchism or of terrorist
attacks, no matter how you define
them, the ratio to between victims, uh,
of overreaction by states to
victims of anarchist tear.
And I'm not apologizing for Atticus tear.
I hate it.
I'm not apologizing for
terror of any kind. I hate it.
But the ratio is 260 to one.
So I suppose there's a lesson to
be learned there or somewhere. Uh,
but it was fun to follow Amy
the Henri, uh, around, even
though I don't admire him.
Uh,
and to try to give you a sense of how
people felt when they hated in the 1890s
and, and that their answer was
not the same answer. A socialist,
which are to take power mostly
through electoral processes,
but to smash the state by blowing it up.
See you on Monday.